[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today we're going to
talk about things that matter you know
things like waffle irons and gold
watches and handbags that are laden with
logos
oh i'm just kidding wait a minute we are
going to talk about on the public
podcast today we're talking about
the things that matter which happens to
be the title of joshua becker's new book
you should have him on
ladies and gentlemen joshua becker is
here
yeah
one of the original inspirations i mean
yes
i i don't think we would be the
minimalist without your inspiration man
yes indeed you definitely helped guide
us and you know when when we first
discovered minimalism it was colin
wright who owned you know 52 things
which was great but seeing your example
was amazing like oh wow you can have a
family and a full-time job and a house
in the suburbs and yeah you can be a
regular person and be a minimalist i'm
in yeah yeah and so joshua becker and
his wife kim and their two kids they
were a big inspiration for us early on
we're gonna talk about today the things
that matter we're gonna answer your
questions this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast
we're going to we're going to talk about
a few things including the areas of
minimalism and other areas in which we
disagree we'll also talk about
overcoming distractions using minimalism
you can check that out at
patreon.com the minimalists your support
keeps our podcast and youtube channel
100 advertisement free because
advertisements suck
joshua becker this is a listener driven
show we're so grateful you're here let's
start with a question from diane on
patreon how do i know what truly matters
what can i do if i'm struggling to find
meaning in my daily activities
i thought we'd start with an easy
question wow i'll say why don't you guys
take a stab at it and then um i can try
to well thankfully i have this book here
it's called things that matter
and on page 210
literally you have this uh chapter about
discovering your purposes
plural purposes right and you've got
this great venn diagram in here where
you talk about the intersection of your
passions your abilities and others needs
now so maybe we could start by
by sort of expanding on those three
areas
passions abilities and uh people's needs
um so i think science backs up my
assumption
uh that
when we live our lives
for other people uh when we live a
selfless life helping other people that
we reach the end of our lives with more
satisfaction in how we chose to live
and so the book is all about how do i
overcome some of these distractions of
money possessions uh leisure
the trivial technology so that i can
live a life that that brings the
greatest good to the greatest number of
people and be proud of the way i lived
throughout my life
and what matters most to us or the good
that we can bring into the world is
always going to differ based on
i think what our talents and abilities
are what our passions are and then
finding that intersection with what
other people's needs are we can be
passionate about things that
don't help other people we can be
passionate about things that we're not
very good at
but when we find that that venn diagram
we find that sweet spot of who am i what
am i passionate about and who can i help
and it looks different for different
different people like my wife would say
like her greatest passion her greatest
purpose is to raise our two children
uh and i would say i want to reach a
million people on my blog like it it i
want to inspire people to unless and so
it looks
it looks different for different people
but i think that's where the diagram
fits together um
yeah i think that we often get
overwhelmed because we think we're born
to do one thing i'm supposed to do just
this one thing and then we go search
around for it wondering whether or not
this is the thing that i'm supposed to
do and in the book what you
lay out is yeah it's true there are many
things that you can be passionate about
now part of passion involves some sort
of excitement meaning like this thing
really makes me feel focused or alive
but sometimes in fact the root of the
word passion means to suffer right past
us means to suffer and so quite often
it's the thing that makes us feel alive
that we have suffered for in order to
get there and so
i think there's a sort of amalgamation
so if i am
tackling diane's question head on uh
really if she can't find her passion
where does she start other than that you
have some worksheets in your book i mean
that's a great place to start but if
you're just listening to the podcast
where did she start
uh i would i would tell her to uh start
doing something
for somebody else
in something you feel
inspired to do
uh this is a little bit unrelated but i
i sound so smart when i say it
uh like i think one of the biggest
problems in the world today is that we
judge people
who are passionate about different
problems than we are
too harshly
and so if you're not passionate about
the exact same problem
i'm passionate about then you're
off and you're you're not compassionate
or you're distracted or whatever it
might be but in reality i think we're
all wired differently and there are a
multitude of problems in the world uh
and so i what's her name diane i i would
tell diane i would say what is one thing
that you are
one problem that you see in the world
that you want to be a part of the
solution yes and then go
maybe you find one person that you can
help in that area or maybe it's a a
non-profit in your community that's
doing that already but just go start
doing something
and allow that ship to steer
because it's out in the ocean rather
than still sitting at port yeah another
way to look at it is you know ask
yourself diane how have you been helped
that has really changed your life or
that has affected your life i mean
that's why we're the minimalists because
we came across minimalism we're like oh
this makes sense yeah i'm gonna start
living with these values and then as we
started living with these values it was
like oh wow like there's a story here i
can pay this forward and help other
people with this idea of minimalism um
yeah i love uh i love the idea of like
what you were saying um figure out a way
that you want to help people like start
there or the ways that you've been
helped we had uh irwin rafael mcmanus on
the podcast
a few months ago and one of the things
he talked about is if your purpose only
involves you it's not actually your
purpose
and i find that the things that make us
feel the most alive involve other people
serving other people connecting with
other people
being with other people
belonging in a way now unfortunately we
try to belong in all these ways that
make us miserable if i just dress the
same way
if i just become part of a club or a
team or i vote the same way that's the
way i can belong even if my values
aren't the same that's not what we're
talking about when we're talking about
pursuing a purpose what you're talking
about is contributing beyond yourself in
a meaningful way
yeah we have a question here from aiden
on facebook
if you restarted your minimalist
journeys with what you know now what
would you change
so ryan last week we actually did an
episode about consumer regrets right and
on the maximal episode on the private
podcast we did an episode called never
buy that again
and so i'm not going to rehash you had
three big consumer regrets you had i had
three and then we talked about these
four non-consumer regrets things that we
would certainly change because i'm not
of the mindset where it's like oh no i
wouldn't want to change a thing in my
life of course you'd be silly if you
didn't have if you had new information
you made the same mistakes
well that's the definition of insanity
but i'm more interested in what joshua
becker
if you were to restart your minimalist
journey knowing what you know now what
would you change man i um
maybe talk about that
that initial dive into
i mean i mean the the first thing that
pops in my mind is i would have started
sooner right but i mean
can that be my answer if that could be
my answer then uh obviously i wish i
would have started when i was when i was
first married and uh didn't waste the
first
you know seven or eight years of my life
buying a house that i didn't need and
stuff that i didn't need
um
that also becomes a distraction because
you write about the distractions of the
past and so one of the things we have to
be careful of is like oh
yes i wish i would have done it sooner
as well i i wish i would have started
writing sooner i wish i would have been
living more intentionally sooner
but then of course if we just say well i
guess i'm the kind of person who doesn't
live intentionally that story about our
past can define our now yeah and even
even that
like maybe i wouldn't go back i mean i i
love that my story
i found minimalism when my son was five
and my daughter was two and
i was cleaning out the garage on a
saturday morning while my son played
alone in the backyard and
my neighbor introduced me to the word
minimalism and
as i had spent hours cleaning out the
garage with my son alone like there was
the realization that
my things weren't just not making me
happy but my things were distracting me
from the things that did bring me
happiness and joy and meaning and life
but i think that i'm able to
connect with people
because of that story
in a way that maybe i wouldn't have been
able to connect with people if i started
when i was in my 20s and that was always
what my what my life looked like so
maybe i won't even go back and change
that i i don't know i don't know what i
would change matt this is always man
does that sound arrogant no no no i i i
don't know i i don't i don't i don't
even know there was a different order of
rooms that i would go through to
declutter i don't know maybe not a
packing party and
started that first i don't know
what can i come up with yeah no i mean
it's a tough question
because i think the same thing it's like
you know i look at my childhood and it
was rough and
um i would love to have it have gone
differently but in the same token like
i'm this version of myself today because
of that crappy childhood so
you know if i didn't you know get those
those lessons or get that trauma who
would i be today i don't know i mean
this is always a interesting question
because of course i wish
you know i wish uh
my dad didn't beat me or my step i
should say my stepdad sorry dad if
you're listening to this
my stepdad uh or i wish that um you know
the swat team didn't kick in our door in
the eighth grade but um but yeah who
knows who i would be without those
experiences and traumas i i like joke
around about how you know when mariah
and i have kids um
because i can look at those traumas and
how they've affected me it's like
how do you give a child the right amount
of trauma
[Laughter]
what's too much trauma what's not enough
trauma
no i think the number of trauma is zero
right that you want to give to a kid but
um it doesn't mean that there aren't
going to be challenges and adversity
along the way and if we if we sort of
nerf the entire world for our children
or for ourselves then we don't develop
into the person that we are right now
yeah i think the trauma is going to come
whether you
try to prescribe the right amount you
want it or not yeah you probably
wouldn't plan injecting in intentional
trauma right right i guess it's more
about how do you deal with the trauma
like on a serious note it is yeah it's
how do you deal with the dramas that
come along um all right no injecting
trauma got it
let's move on to our callers if you have
a question or comment for our podcast
give us a call 406 219 7839 or email a
voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists.com we have a question today
from crystal in saint cloud minnesota so
way back a couple of months ago i
decided you know what i'm gonna always
have a car payment i might as well go
and buy a fancy car with all the bells
and whistles and leather interiors
sunroof
um and that obviously came with a really
high
car payment and high price tag and i'm
on the hook for that for the next seven
years since then i've you know really
adopted um a new lifestyle and a new
outlook um trying to be more minimalist
and the large car payment that i have to
pay every month does not align with my
values nor can i actually afford it um
so i don't want to take on a second job
just to drive this fancy car so i'm
wondering
what can i do can i return the car to
the dealership
i'm sure i would take a loss on that is
that loss worth it or should i just you
know i'm stuck with it and
pay it and then not repeat the same
mistakes um in seven years from now once
it's paid off i've looked online uh
for an answer and haven't really come up
with much
so crystal
this is we were actually on the maximum
off so we were arguing about
shoulds
and uh this is one of those mimetic
shoulds everyone oh i guess i should
have a car payment right our society
tells us that's what you're supposed to
do and one of the things that so many
people
joshua they got really upset with me
recently because we danny put out a tick
tock video and there was
a video of me
saying
if you have to finance a car you can't
afford it
now i called up an economist friend of
mine because so many people i had
backlash hundreds of hateful comments oh
my god and and
just by definition that ends up being
true if you have to finance something
and it wasn't a judgment of anyone else
if i wanted a lamborghini i'd have to
finance it i because i can't afford it i
can't pay for a lamborghini and
unfortunately that's where crystal is
right now she's been told by society i
guess you're always going to have a car
payment you should have a car payment
right and now she's even contemplating
do i have do i get a second job in order
to pay for the car that takes me to my
first job
and you talk about this in the book
the sort of distraction of more
possessions but then also this is
another distraction of
adulation or applause what are people
gonna think of me if i if i drive a
really nice car
they're gonna think nice things about me
right and so
i mean obviously we follow dave ramsey
pretty closely we work with dave ramsey
on some stuff and and we ryan and i
don't do any debt other than mortgage
debt and even then i'd prefer not to
have it
i i personally would never want to have
a a car payment because i think it
restricts some of my freedom do you
share that
viewpoint uh concerning car payments
yeah yeah never had a car payment um wow
i got uh i got real good advice um when
i was when i was young uh they said um
um save up the money
uh this was when i was in college so
i was driving my parents vehicle so i
suppose i should count that um
save up the money and then whatever cash
you have on hand use that to buy a car
and then whatever your car payment would
have been save that amount into the bank
and then whenever that
beater car wears out you can sell it and
whatever you have saved up use that to
buy the next car and then just put your
car payment into a bank so a little bit
uh just going it uh just doing it
backwards and we've uh we've done that
our our entire lives and so never had a
car payment that's why you have bentley
now because you just kept saving and
saving what is a bentley payment five
thousand dollars a month all right
granted started out with you know my
parents car so um i mean there's a
little bit of help from the very first
car which is probably the toughest one
to buy
uh i i don't know what specific advice
uh what was what was the name my name is
crystal uh crystal
i mean you're at
i mean i
i mean i think the specific advice for
crystal is to is to honestly do the math
um
i mean i think the market for used cars
has never been better than it is right
now and so i like
i would do the math like what what can
you sell this car for um are you
underwater in it how long would it take
to get on the right side of it
um
maybe sell it now maybe um
yeah i don't know probably wouldn't know
unless you lose a bunch of money on it
right away at the beginning then you you
just take the you just take the loss and
yeah i mean i mean how is she gonna buy
a car if she's underwater several
thousand hundred if i don't if i'm in
her shoes that i could find a way to get
rid of the car even if it's a loss of
money let's say the car is a for the
sake of easy math here it's a thirty
thousand dollar car and you can get
twenty five thousand dollars for it
because the market's
fairly solid right now you're gonna lose
say you're underwater five thousand
dollars it's a fi the question you ask
here is
how much did this mistake cost me it
cost you five thousand dollars right as
opposed to continuing to make this a
forty thousand because with interest is
gonna be a forty thousand dollar mistake
over the next seven years the seven year
mistake and so while crystal i'm not
going to tell you what to do i know
certainly what i would do if i were in
your shoes i'd buy a 2 000 beater
whatever i could find it's going to get
me from point a to point b
it may even inject a little bit of
discomfort in my life right oh no the
air conditioning doesn't really work
well in this thing oh no there's no
bluetooth in this car right whatever am
i going to do
without these luxuries but also
recognizing that now i don't have the
burden i would much rather drive a car
that is paid for than have the burden of
a monthly car payment every single month
and i have a lot of compassion for
crystal because i put myself in this
situation there was a part there was a
time where i had three luxury cars and
then i stumbled across
becomingminimalist.com and i'm like what
am i doing i'm making three car payments
and i'm spending all this money to
impress a bunch of people
who aren't really that impressed they
might say oh sweet car or whatever
or even worse they'll say oh it must be
nice
rondelle talks about this sometimes
about you know the the sort of people in
your life if they approach life in a way
where it's it's it's a judgmental sort
of thing hey you know it must be nice to
well no it wasn't actually nice it just
looked nice
paying three car payments every month is
not nice it's incredibly stressful and
it's
it actually we buy these things to give
us security they bring us more in
security
yeah
and you know like this is not well like
when you mention the um
if you have to take a loan out on a car
you can't afford it that's not there's
no value judgment attached to that
i mean it's it just is it's not good
it's not bad it's just it's just a
statement
so yeah i don't think it's immoral to
exactly to death yeah yeah so you know
what crystal's going through right now
it's what it is doing is it's anxiety
producing so how can you lift that
stress out of your life i mean
when i first went down the road to
minimalism i had a car payment
i looked at
how much i needed to pay off i went to
craigslist i put it up for sale
um and then i went and
got i think at the time the corolla was
probably worth 3 000 bucks maybe 3 500
bucks
um
so yeah i mean i went from a nice
luxury vehicle to a corolla and i got
judged for it like i'll never forget
like the first
first time i went to go uh i was on i
was on a board and i was leading this
meeting i won't say what because i don't
want to like call anyone out but um the
uh the ceo of the company of the board i
was on we were like walking out to the
parking lot and he saw my corolla he's
like what is this i'm like this is my
car man i had to get rid of my car
payment you know a minimalist now like i
got to start making better decisions
he's like
i don't like it and i'm like well i
don't care if you like it or not like
this is what i had to do to to move my
life forward so yeah crystal you might
have to get a little bit lesser of a car
but
you could take the approach i did i mean
even let's say you don't have two
thousand dollars on hand uh you can take
your your what you owe on it add two
thousand dollars to it and then yeah go
on craigslist and maybe find someone
who's willing to pay you that much for
the car but i agree with you becker like
it has never been a better time to sell
used cars right now like they are in
pretty high demand
yeah and i think the cost of this
mistake will help you avoid making the
same mistake again and again
now that you've realized it because the
problem is when we finance cars we keep
making the same mistake because we think
that's what we're supposed to do i'm
supposed to have a monthly car payment
for the rest of my life yeah
let's turn over to the live stream
alabama what do we got any questions
we have a question from ann i find
myself putting minimalism at the center
of my focus rather than using it as a
tool to make room for the things that
matter in life do you identify with this
feeling
becker thoughts
i
never
set minimalism as the greatest goal
in my life
um
and i i almost i almost feel bad saying
that and i'm i'm like really searching
my heart to to make sure i'm i'm true in
saying that
uh and i i think it is true like i
uh that saturday morning i wanted to
have more time available with my family
and so i wanted to own less stuff and i
always saw minimalism would help me get
there
now
as i started
pursuing this
uh minimalism became much more of an
obsession
to me like as i saw owning less
improving my life i
i became consumed with what else can i
get rid of
and
honey why did you buy that thing and
like even even probably to this day 13
years later like i still
we had a package show up from amazon
last night and uh i'm like what is this
kids like what we don't know who bought
it i think my son bought it from college
and shipped it to our house but i'm like
who's buying this um
but it it certainly became uh it
certainly became
uh something that i obsessed over uh to
a degree
um and i i don't know if i i don't know
if you could change that from the
beginning i feel like i had to
to kind of go through that and recognize
it and
say hey this has become a little bit
unhealthy in
how i'm talking to my wife like this has
become unhealthy and how i'm just
constantly scouring my house trying to
find things that i should be getting rid
of and shouldn't have
and so in that way i think it became a
little bit of an obsession but
i mean i wrote a blog post really early
on that like
i don't want to be known
as a good minimalist that that was never
what i wanted to be known for like i
wanted to be known as a
a a faithful follower
of god i wanted to be known as a good
father i wanted to be known as a
faithful husband i wanted to be known as
you know someone who made a difference
in the world like like this is who i
want to be remembered for not not being
a minimalist so yeah
i'm sure it's not uncommon that um
minimalism becomes
the obsession
right away
um but for me it was it was always a
means to an end but me that's just how i
was introduced to it
when i read the book at first i thought
it was going to tell me what things
matter meaning like what possessions of
my house are gonna be the the most
useful or most valuable to me
and then i realized early on what you
were talking about are all of these
distractions that keep us from the
things that matter and one of those
distractions that you talk about in the
book is stuff
and that becomes a distraction but in a
way
getting rid of the stuff if we're solely
focused on get that's still a
distraction by stuff and so what you're
what you're pointing out here is we
often trade consumerism for
simply decluttering
whereas with minimalism the decluttering
is a tool that allows us to uncover what
is important whether it is your faith
your family the activities the
contribution beyond yourself your
passions it's not about being a good
minimalist just like it's not about
buying
when we buy a hammer we don't obsess
over the hammer the hammer does the job
it is the tool and in many ways
minimalism is a tool that uncovers the
things that matter i was very early on
um uh in this process getting rid of
things and i
um
i was surprised at
how
introspective
i became
about owning less stuff
and i it was a it was a short blog post
i used to blog like once or twice a day
and just a couple paragraphs at a time
like that was what becoming
minimalist.com used to be and i remember
writing how
i'm just surprised at how
what deep questions about my life this
process is bringing to the forefront
and uh
dustin hershberger i still remember the
name commented back on the blog and uh
he said it seems to me minimalism would
force questions of values
upon you and uh i said that is exactly
what is happening like you can't decide
what you need to keep
until you get well
the process of deciding what to keep
can't help but include like what do i
want to do with my life what do i want
to be with my life what do i want to
accomplish with my life what things are
important to me uh can't help but
surface as we're going through this
going through this process yeah yeah i
mean yeah it's minimalism as a tool to
help you uncover
the important things in your life and
you know
man when you get rid of distractions
sometimes like that's the hard part
it's like oh man like what do i want but
if minimalism becomes the focus i mean
you can't
you can't make room for more minimalism
eventually you're gonna get to a point
where you do have to ask these tough
questions
we did an episode on spartanism which is
sort of the other side of hoarding
they're both on the ocd continuum but
spartanists are people who
can't hold on to anything
and i think minimalism somewhere in
between it allows me to hold on to the
things that are useful that are valuable
whether they're actual physical things
but they're also the people that enrich
my life and i enrich their lives
and so
we were able to hold on just like when
my daughter is climbing the monkey bars
you have to be able to hold on and let
go in order for it to work if you can do
nothing but let go you're slipping and
falling right if you can do nothing but
holding on you stay stuck
i bet you the person asking this
question
um
could probably identify what minimalism
is making room for yeah and uh
that's
maybe they don't even realize what
minimalism has opened them up towards
um but yeah maybe they're focused on
minimalism because it's allowed them to
get out of debt it's allowed them to
spend more time with family it's allowed
them to you know leave that toxic
relationship whatever it is um
i'm sure
yeah i mean there's some good side
effects happening from minimalism yeah
definitely before we go into the
lightning round ryan i wanted to reach
out to crystal here in saint cloud
minnesota and say we're going to be in
your city well almost we're going to be
in minneapolis right down the street
from you the love people use things to
where we have two american cities left
chicago minneapolis both this month
we'll give you a couple tickets crystal
for the minneapolis event we'll also be
in toronto and vancouver later this year
the minimalists.com
tour if you'd like tickets to any of
those final four love people use things
events ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions you can text your comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed now joshua becker this is
where we and our guests we answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
we call them minimal maxims but really
what we do is we monitor on a bit until
podcast sean he tweets out something
pithy and beautiful he puts it in the
show notes so people can copy and share
our pithy answers on social media i am
gonna test all of his skills
teasing out something
i'm a member of the sandwich generation
meaning i take care of my aging parents
as well as my children how can i
prioritize my needs without forsaking
those i have to care for
now ryan is part of the sandwich eating
generation
i just love sandwiches
dude that was on my okay cupid profile
and
mariah was like
because it was a joke but she was like
oh i like sandwiches too
but i'm just saying that's what brought
us together our love for sandwiches
perfect i know she can't eat sandwiches
because she's gluten intolerant anyway
thanks to you
you've ruined her life
poor mariah i know i question her
judgment all the time
joshua and that's question here
so taking care of aging parents as well
as my children how can i prioritize my
needs without forsaking
those i have to care for
what thoughts do you have
oh my goodness um
my first thought is thank you
uh thank you for
doing that uh thank you for
raising your children intentionally
thank you for taking care of your
parents
not everyone does um so i would start
there
um i
uh you might have more in the moment
wisdom
um but i would i would remind her that
that this is uh a season of life
uh where she's probably gonna have to
give
more of herself um
uh there'll come a time where her kids
are older and she won't have to put as
much effort in
raising them
there will come a time where her parents
aren't around anymore
and won't require that energy
but i would
i would look for help from your friends
as best you possibly can
and i would realize that
that this season won't uh won't last
forever but you are doing
a noble thing
and um
you should be tired
when you go to bed at night but you
should be proud of the day
i know you're getting super emotional on
this um what what bring what stirs up
those emotions in you what are you
thinking about
um
i'm just thinking that uh that
that she doesn't have to do that i mean
like
not everyone
um raises their children well and not
everyone uh takes care of their aging
parents well and uh to hear that she is
uh makes me
proud to get to meet her over the over
the internet yeah i think she needs to
hear that if she's not hearing it yeah
amen
i think quite often
we talk about our priorities right
and it seems to me that
you've annette you've identified what
your priorities are right now
and unlike me in my 20s i said a lot of
things are my priorities right but the
funny thing is priorities don't even
exist priority exists you know priority
simply means
the first thing
and in my 20s i had about 300 the first
things
and then by definition everything was
valuable to me so no nothing was
valuable to me so if i have a pithy
answer for you it's simply that our
priorities are showcased not by what we
say but how we spend our days
and how you're spending your days right
now sounds to me like you're doing
something incredibly meaningful it's
also really difficult because maybe you
feel like you don't have enough time for
yourself and yes there may be times
where you have to make that time for
yourself you so that you can have you
can fill the cup so you can pour it out
into the the people that you you need to
pour out because you can't as you say in
the book you can't pour out anything
from an empty cup right and so i think
maybe that's where
the
the discontent sets in here or the
stress is like i don't feel like i have
enough to give
and you may not be able to do everything
that you think
you're supposed to do everything that
you should do
but it sounds to me like if you're
contributing beyond yourself to these
other people you're doing something that
is noble and
you you need to be applauded for that
yeah
amen
uh
my pithy answer is boundaries protect
boundless love
so i love what you said becker about
this being a season of life
and
there might be some boundaries she needs
to set maybe it's maybe it's with her
kids or her parents but it might be
outside of that
where she's putting too much on herself
that
is really uh depleting her tank or maybe
she's you know she's at a deficit each
day
but
since it is a season because i know
with our friends and our family like we
would just want to say yes to everything
and we can't we really can't
and i think if there's someone in your
life that you can set a boundary with uh
if it's if they're close to you they're
going to understand you can say to them
hey look i got i have a lot of
responsibility right now with my parents
i have a lot of responsibilities right
now with my kids i would love to do that
thing for you or with you
um but but i have to say no so i can say
yes taking care of my parents and my
kids
and uh i'm gonna have to say no for
quite a while um but the people who
love and respect you and want you to be
happy they're gonna understand those
boundaries and it's
it's not an unloving thing
to set boundaries and i feel like when
we when i tell someone no i often feel
like oh man i'm being a jerk or i'm
they're gonna think i'm being selfish or
whatever it is but if you explain to
them what you're saying yes to um
doesn't come across as so selfish
well we got a lot more to talk about but
real quick
for right here right now there's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists ryan and i have worked on
nine philanthropic projects over the
last decade or so a couple with joshua
becker the the hope effect which is the
charity he started and helped build a
few orphanages with them over the years
we just started working on a new project
right now with dave ramsey
we're going to educate every middle
school student and every high school
student in dayton ohio our hometown
we're raising money to do that ryan and
i just paid money to educate the first
100 students it's about financial
literacy so we've partnered with ramsey
to get their curriculum literally into
every middle school and every high
school in dayton ohio and if this goes
well quickly we're gonna expand it
beyond the borders of of our hometown
into other cities across the united
states and elsewhere getting that
curriculum out there so we can set kids
up without debt without the stress
without the anxiety without borrowing
from their future
in order to do something right now
giving them that financial literacy
because the average american indebted
household
has 97
775 dollars in non-mortgage debt
and so we've set ourselves up
in a sort of prison a prison of debt and
so we want to help a whole bunch of kids
middle school kids high school kids you
can help out with that if you go to the
minimalists.com
education you can find all the details
the frequently asked questions
25
will provide the curriculum for one
middle school student 45
for one high school student or if you
can just donate five bucks that would
help us out as well the minimalists.com
slash education
alabama what else you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi my name is morgan i'm from milwaukee
wisconsin i'm applying regards to um
someone who's asked about their camping
gear and having all that stuff like in
their house and wanting to minimize it
one option that we actually have in
milwaukee is the urban ecology center
it's a nonprofit
and uh this group you donate 35 a year
as a single person and it really just
goes towards keeping the nonprofit going
they try and get community involvement
and education around on the environment
and preserve the wild license in
milwaukee um but the awesome thing about
them is that they uh offer free camping
gear and uh kayaks and bikes like
anything that you want to rent you can
run for up to three days or longer if
you get 20 requests i'm sure they're not
the only city that there's an option
like this out there so just something to
keep in mind that there might be even
like community groups in the area that
help you have access to those items but
not have to have them in your own home
hi this is bethany from maine i started
minimizing earlier this year when i was
pregnant my son is now six months old
after much deliberation i decided to
start a small memory box for him
as i have enjoyed having some items from
my childhood
growing up and this may add value to his
life at some point i will save a few
items such as his hospital bracelet
birth announcement and a baby outfit as
he gets older he can decide if he wants
to contribute any items to his box but
any saved items have to fit in the bin
the important thing is that i don't
attach sentiment to these items and
project my own emotions on my son he
will decide what adds value when he is
an adult he can choose to keep some all
or no items i will allow him to make
this choice with no guilt or
expectations on my part
all right y'all big thanks to our friend
joshua becker his new book it's called
things that matter you can find it over
at
becomingminimalist.com that's his blog
he's also going on tour 12 cities in the
united states you can find those cities
at becoming minimalist.com this book
just came out today
and joshua i want to thank you i want to
acknowledge you for writing this i know
you said uh
we were talking about this on the live
stream but there was a point after you
wrote the minimalist home and then the
more of less which were two previous
books i'm not going to write another
book i think i'm done with that
and then you felt a calling to write
this because we are so distracted and
it's not just with stuff it's all these
other areas and we talk about on the
maximum episode we'll talk about the
eight areas of distraction but in this
book you dive deep into
all these things that get in the way of
a meaningful life and i'll say thank you
for the just thank you for writing this
yeah
well thank you for the kind words i uh i
hope that
i hope the thoughts in the book uh spark
new thoughts um for people and uh
provide
help and thoughts and
um
uh i i just
there's a lot of good available in the
world i mean there's just a lot of good
that's being bottled up um and like i
say in the book i think we're all
created to to bring a good into the
world
uh and the the less we're distracted by
things that don't matter the the more
good we can bring and the more people we
can help and so i hope the book um
does that on a personal level for people
and uh for society as a whole so thanks
for letting me
chat with you guys thank you so much
you're awesome man check out his youtube
channel as well we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well as becoming
minimalist the book as well and his tour
the things that matter tour coming to a
city near you or just a nice little road
trip away
sometimes that happens right people like
come to yeah move or go several states
over to see an event you'll see quite a
few of those yeah see him while he's on
the road when you have a chance for
added value this week ryan
graham colton put out a new ep
the ep is called remember win
and it's a few new songs but then his
most popular song is a song called best
days and it's like a kind of rocky song
he does this acoustic version of it i
thought we'd end the show today because
the song really highlights
well
giving up the things we thought were
important so we can enjoy the best days
of our lives and the best days of our
lives are right now we can uncover that
when we get rid of the things that don't
matter and make room for the things that
do so enjoy the song from graham colton
this is the acoustic version of best
days if you're watching on youtube i'm
sure they can click right here right
jordan somewhere up here and you can
find it by the way ryan we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
what is joshua becker's definition of
minimalism and how does it differ from
the minimalist's definition
what are the eight biggest distractions
in most people's daily lives i've heard
the minimalists dislike logos
but what's the problem with wearing
logos plus a million more questions for
joshua becker and the minimalists and if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain access to hundreds of
hours of private archives recordings of
live events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
tiktok instagram and twitter at the
minimalist if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus
podcast sean alabama jordan no more
social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn if you leave
here today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it